where we had Batman and Superman earlier
now we've got all of Famer Reggie Miller
known as Batman known as Batman to know
Superman is on a Superman asset
management almost Superman before this
he was Superman before though you were
then Drake and Drake is here as well and
certainly drinks a Hall of Famer - yes
exactly it's certainly one of these one
of the highlights of all-star week here
in Toronto was as much ballyhooed
head-to-head matchup in ping-pong or
table tennis call it what you will
between the Drake and Reggie Miller and
you knew it was big when the guy doing
the play-by-play was Marv Albert like to
welcome everyone here to what is
actually the most anticipated event of
all-star weekend it is the Reggie Miller
Invitational ping-pong tournament the
Challenger the global ambassador for the
Toronto Raptors and untold an excellent
ping-pong player drink and a five-time
NBA all-star band with lightning speed
he says his record is 165 an old and
paper Reggie Miller each game will go to
21 points you have to win by two points
winner is the best of three all right
guys we're all safe good luck to both of
you
let's go baby
all right so here we go Game one do you
guys take us through it always
interesting
I underestimated his skill level and
returning the ball I thought I'm gonna
be a little bit more
but he did a great job of being able to
turn my serve you know I'll say I was
watching you warm up and I think that
you you so you're a ringer
I want to tell you later despite despite
popular belief Reggie is a
multi-talented guy yeah
empowered I believe gun trade you know
what happened after the first guy win
and spiked at one time but you winked at
LeBron yeah that kind of took the edge
like a lot of times at oh I'm an Italian
can celebrate I'm gonna tell you that's
one thing about Reggie man no he's uh
he's a fierce fierce competitor I mean
as you can see you know that was my
point right there but you see the sweat
starts building up here and and and as
things start slipping away from him he
turned you lived up the white line I'm
gonna say there's a union to live you
lived on those white lines that's my
game about five points just on those
lines allows it you feel good they're
actually trying don't let it out save
America you noticing a highlight whose
kidneys width on the background on wood
team said about George Drake takes on
Britt kick scheme so I want game one and
then what happened is what happened is
Reggie started to read my serve so I
could I was serving him I was serving
flat and he just started but I mean it
was yeah yeah that's that's Olympic
quality stuff right there well what's
interesting is because Drake does not
play with a traditional paddle which
it's not a traditional I don't play with
a traditional about me doesn't see what
does that mean
patting on it he doesn't have padding on
his paddle here so there's not a lot of
power coming back towards me so I could
not transfer power back to him so I had
to play a little bit more defensively
I'm more of an offensive player that's
almost more really sandpaper paddles you
got yeah I think those are I think those
are those are illegal now so I try and
play with just you know it's the flat I
miss the flour civil rights was not that
intricate about he kill me right now
light up at a game of pisses that's what
the room was the room was quiet and it
was it was attached oh [ __ ] you
now when was he hitting nets and white
lines but he was living on my serve yeah
okay you're not supposed to celebrate on
lek unlit by the way we're so I
apologize for that celebrated oh I could
see that was that Shaq attack baby you
know he had got my heels in the third
game it was 17 11 yeah he can't be on my
heels in this game he had count 1812 and
slipping away but then you could see his
eyes start changing here I hope they do
a close-up on reg we call his eyes [ __ ]
I started the ball has to go in the air
I start I started to see Spike Lee
that's what happened 18 12 I had a look
at him look look you see look he's
getting way too intense with me now I
can't even focus horses yeah I'm talking
this is where I threw it away right here
Oh
1900 this is a this is the most it's the
most devastating moment of the last few
years that was it what oh man what a
match there was it was so intense yeah
it was Stan it was a Oh quiet little
bill in a belt oh yeah we mean that's
baby
so can we say what we agreed to just a
second ago which is I so I asked I just
asked and I want to say it in front of
all the guys I asked for another shot at
the belt during the conference finals so
we can know that's all I'm SOI man do
you come into the United States and I'm
gonna come I'm gonna play on it on your
turn if you can't beat us in Canada you
can't beat us
Thank You Chuck but I will say this he
wanted to wait a year I'm like a year no
there's a conference finals are a the
highlight of our basketball seasons
right we have Easter West's we have the
West got the world yeah um Toronto but
I'm just ready I just want to thank you
for representing a 9-2 stays well if
it's used to me to Drake because Kenny
said he was gonna introduce me to drink
and I said Drake when I walked up drink
I said
Kenan said he was going to introduce me
to you and you say it Kimmy whoo oh here
you go
here you go well I ain't Dre I
appreciate you taking camel ooh knowing
yesterday too
honestly man boy with the his side over
uncle Reggie side eyes a little her I
have to watch my son I have to make sure
he was on the right side a little nephew
out there who I helped raise and voted
over to Drake who is definitely you know
what though it was a who's hesitant
about it I didn't got forced it on him
you know so but it was always an
incredible match I love you guys thank
you for the opportunity and you sir yeah
that's your question I you know this is
my favorite city in the world to run to
and you're from here I'm glad you so
you're really getting the touch are you
really glad that did a lot of these
people like Kenan said man this is an
incredible City yeah just great exposure
for you and your city I think I think
aside from exposure I think it's just
about what these people deserve you know
we
fans we have we have people that are in
the city that are so proud to be from
here that are always supporting and they
just deserve this tonight you know I
mean yesterday was one of the most
legendary dunk competitions I maybe ever
seen in my life and tonight I think
these guys are gonna put on a show for a
city that's deserving you know by the
way guys he's doing the intros if you
didn't know yeah oh yeah a week for you
man yeah I'm trying to draw well we have
a tradition yes we have a tradition okay
Shaq you I usually don't do beats in
front and check freestyle but Lisa
especially he's gonna have a bean ball
pause let's go oh man oh man jeez yeah
are you doing the bars or am i doing the
bars who went through got tomorrow
alright yo sitting at the - OH
the original Oh Pete you old man oh man
mmm-hmm not again not again oh yeah
all right we ready we're gonna look
kaboom well I learned the game from
William Wesley you can never check hide
the bad for the boys that didn't get the
message
that it felt like I'm gonna cover lethal
weapon bad it felt like I'm shorter
nineties
holy laughs is that right here our team
director what